did you know that when you get this boss
below around 25 health that this can
happen
this grab attack did
2410 damage to our character we actually
had to hack our health higher just to
survive it so this might just be the
single most devastating grab attack in
any from software game i think
but what's really fascinating about this
grab attack is that there are two
versions of astell that you can fight in
game right there's the natural born of
the void creature in the ainsle river
and there's the stars of darkness
variant in the yellow annex tunnel but
in our testing only the stars of
darkness variant of astell can clone
itself and use this attack the other one
can't i wonder why
there's definitely more to these
creatures than meets the eye
and it's that same eye that brings us to
the falling star beast
so two of these can be found and fought
in elden ring but these two are only
young supposedly because a full-grown
falling star beast can also be fought
atop mount gilmere but the secret here
is that these creatures are only stage
one of an evolutionary chain
the mouthpiece of the falling star beast
looks a lot like the mouthpiece that
many antlion larvae have and since
larvae are basically immature insects
they're bound to go through a pupa or
chrysalis stage before they become an
adult
which brings us to the malformed star
enemies this is stage two so gone is the
quadruped type of animal and in its
place is this hidden contorted
monstrosity which hangs stationary as
many bugs commonly do in this stage
here the beast is much larger and sports
multiple limbs
finally the skull that was previously
only slightly protruding has now become
fully visible and here it fires rocks
and attempts to bite those that come too
close waiting for the day that it can
reach its full potential as an astel
sprouting wings it now fights you with
an enormous tail new attacks and six
fully realized limbs
number three around the lands between
stand several rises and to enter these
you're often required to solve a puzzle
but probably the most difficult puzzle
to solve on your own stands here in
northeastern leonia its hint reads
erudition light the way and to get
inside you'll need the erudition gesture
and a glintstone crown helmet both of
which are within the rya lucaria academy
and the combination of wearing the crown
and performing the gesture causes the
magic gems within most glintstone crowns
to glow brightly illuminating the way
through the seal
showing just how clever you are but what
i really want to know is who the hell
was the first one to figure this one out
without looking it up
next i want to show off some invisible
bridges in eldon ring which might still
be hidden to many players
so the first bridge can be found as a
solution to yet another rise puzzle the
heretical tower rise in the mountaintop
of the giants starting on the opposite
side of the ravine in the north you can
see a distant stone bridge leading into
the tower carefully follow this path and
you'll find yourself inside being inside
by these means will break the seal by
the traditional entrance as you defend
yourself from the avionics soldiers
inside your reward at the top is the
powerful founding reign of stars sorcery
the second area containing concealed
walkways can be found in the hidden path
to the halig tree
after taking your leap of faith from the
rail here head across to the left to
find some valuable loot then another
path begins from this alcove carefully
navigate across the abyss to find some
vulgar militants who guard three
sacramental buds from this exit looking
in the westerly direction the keen eye
will spot this entry being slightly
lower than the current level walk a
straight line here being wary of the
small decline you take to get inside
here you'll find more enemies more loot
and a path that leads on to a stray
mimic tear boss the traditional way
we've always revealed these paths is
with rainbow stones or now even better
rainbow stone arrows but eldon ring has
given us yet another valuable tool
hawfrost stomp which reveals just how
much stable ground is in front of you
making it perfect for navigating
invisible corners and spiral turns this
should prevent you from falling to your
death and speaking of which when it
comes to falling elden ring appears to
have a system in place to help prevent
unintentional falls
so when you're faced with a sheer drop
like this one attacks facing that
direction will be met with a protective
barrier that prevents you from falling
these barriers seem to exist in places
where there are large unbroken folds
beneath you making them really useful
when you're navigating those invisible
paths discussed earlier just swing away
and take note of when you seem to stop
moving as you've likely reached the edge
that being said this method doesn't work
for all cliff faces but where of using
this method against rocky choppy ledges
that don't have a clearly defined fall
below them like this one here
gestures are also very capable of
causing death by gravity unfortunately
it seems like prayer won't be able to
save you here speaking of dropping down
did you know that there are several
branches and ledges that you can
navigate behind the b steel sanctum in
caled risking some really long drops
down here will reward your tenacity with
the dragon crest shield talisman and the
cincadia the talisman will provide a
nice boost to physical damage negation
however the true diamond in the rough is
the dagger nearby
modeled after an italian short sword of
the same name cinco dia means five
fingers and it references the
five-fingered grip that the weapon
requires but eldon ring takes this
symbolism further and even shows a
skeletal hand along the blade fittingly
the cincadia also boosts bestial
incantations like that signature
five-fingered claw attack this weapon
works great in your offhand especially
when combined with the claw mark seal
which adds another 10 boost you can even
two-hand the claw mark seals and make
better use of its unique strength
scaling and the best way to maximize
your damage in elden ring is by
assigning stats to match proper weapon
scaling and of course everyone knows
that the assigned letters of s through
to e determine how strong your scaling
damage will be but it's actually not as
simple as that because take a look at
this short sword and compare it to the
lord sworn straight sword so both of
these are d in strength and dexterity so
they should scale identically right
then why is it that the lord sworn
straight sword comes up as a red poorer
quality letter when compared in the user
interface
turns out that these letter allocations
are actually only break points or tiers
and that each weapon actually has a
hidden scaling figure or value of zero
through to 200. so in this example here
the short sword actually has a stronger
scaling value when compared to the lord
sworn sword even though they're both
listed as d
and while it's difficult to figure out
exact scaling values it's definitely
something you should be aware of
especially when comparing weapons
another thing that you'll want to be
aware of you know if you've been playing
eldon ring for a really long time
is soap
it can be really useful in certain
situations
so when you roll through a poison or rot
swamp your character will be physically
coated in the element and status buildup
will increase because you're covered
this build-up will continue even after
you exit the pool
now this coating will eventually wear
off but soap can remove it instantly
soap will also remove any blood stains
that you've managed to gather throughout
your journey
and similar to soap if you roll through
a poison pool and then stand under or
move into rain then the poison will come
off as well this effect is immediate so
if the pool is outside in the rain then
you'll find that coating can never occur
and you can also roll in water to
cleanse the poison
some pots in elden ring even have water
in them as well just for this purpose in
researching soap we discovered a few
other interesting details
first if you coat yourself by rolling
into scarlet rot and then you exit the
swamp and you let the scarlet rot status
fully build up based on the body coating
for some strange reason this body
coating will trigger a less deadly
version of the rot than if you had just
stayed in the pool to activate it it
appears to take about 50 less health per
tick if you do it this way so if you're
crossing this enormous lake of rot what
i would do is let the rot status effect
fully build up outside of the pool and
then you can just have this weaker
version applied to you for your entire
journey across next there are also two
types of poison in eldon ring there's
normal and deadly
deadly deals twice as much damage per
second when active and it does this over
a shorter period of time as well which
is also beneficial
weapons like the serpent bone blade and
venomous fang actually deal this deadly
poison making them far superior in my
opinion to regular poison infusions as
far as dps goes so pick your poison
carefully for number 12 consider the
nomadic merchants as well as being
valuable allies and skilled information
brokers many are also very talented
musicians and thanks to securodube on
youtube we now know how extremely
accurate they're playing is their
fingers and bowing actually match what a
real instrument should look like when
used which is some incredible intention
to detail as you can see here with their
finger work along the bridge
prepare to cry by the way but staying
with these merchants a little longer
their wares are also very unique
alongside the arrows and the pots that
they peddle they also sell information
in the form of cookbooks and notes but
did you know that these notes are
actually marked to help identify which
merchant they came from take a look at
merchant kali for example see those blue
and white accented feathers in his cap
you'll also find those on the bottom of
the notes that he sells these note
feathers are basically a signature
flourish from their original author
for number 14 here is a simple but
useful discovery that still exists as of
patch 1.05 and that is it is technically
possible to pause elden ring all you
have to do is find your way to the menu
explanation section by pressing the help
button in a menu
this will effectively freeze everything
in the game while it is open
normal sounds will just continue to
operate around you and even status
builder will pause i guess this is one
way to step away from the game while
you're in the wild although you should
get in the habit of quitting out when
you do this especially because quit out
is actually a valid tool that you can
use when you're in the middle of combat
or when you fall off a ledge even
next here's a secret that was discovered
all the way back in the network test
thanks to early research completed by
lance macdonald did you know that
melania's cutscene can occur in other
locations rather than just the typical
gatefront graces that most people use as
long as it's your third side of grace
most graces in limgrave will actually
trigger this cutscene my favorite one to
go to is actually the seaside ruins i
think that one looks cool but there's
also a gear like south
the third church of america the bridge
of sacrifice the murk water coast they
all work perfectly one new addition to
elden ring that you might not know about
is your ability to block while
backstepping with this shield bearers
can get a little bit of protection while
moving away from an oncoming attack in
pve this is a helpful way to give you
extra space and a barrier especially
against persistent enemies like dogs and
rats and while backsteps admittedly
aren't super powerful the attack that
you do after a backstep can be
these attacks are similar to your
running attack animations but for some
weapons the backstep attack animation is
particularly good for example power
stanced greatswords actually have a
backstep l1 there's a simultaneous
thrust and power stands talbots have a
double consecutive thrust let me know in
the comments if there are any other
weapons that have really great backstep
attacks because while they're sometimes
useful in pve to turn your defense into
offense where they really shine is in
pvp
here high level players often use
backstep attacks to mix up their
animations and the best players can be
seen backstepping into opponents just to
trigger this attack sometimes
so if you're not using these in pvp
especially you really should weave them
into your play style many people really
don't know what to expect when you pull
off this technique
and speaking of invading so you can
invade with the finger items but if you
manage to pick up both fingers during
your playthrough then you can actually
use them both to invade more efficiently
using one finger forces you to stand and
wait to invade while this message
regularly pops up but one thing i
noticed from watching auroboros streams
is that by alternating between two
fingers constantly you effectively reset
your attempt to invade meaning you're
more likely to invade a player as soon
as an invasion slot opens up and despite
being used for the same purpose the
bloody and recusant fingers are actually
slightly different
this is mostly a case of thematics as
the fingers represent two different
factions
one for the recusants of the volcano
manor and another one for the followers
of moog the lord of blood but did you
notice that each finger has its own
signature invasion music have a listen
and let me know what you think is the
better theme for your pvp antics
for number 20 elden ring is full of
little things that help immerse you into
its world and being able to sheath your
weapons is one of those
yes this is a very minor thing but it
does make you look a little bit more
presentable in cut scenes or when
talking to npcs and if you're someone
who records footage like me then this is
a very handy tool so to shade your sword
you need to ensure that your offhand is
empty and then you tap triangle and l1
to stash your blade away and most
weapons are simply slung at your side or
over your shoulder but some swords have
these beautiful scabbards that really
are worth showing off the glintstone
chris the banished knights greatsword
and the rivers of blood katana are just
a few examples of weapons that have
detailed scabbards that you'll want to
admire you should always be conscious of
your character's elden bling because you
never know whose world your character
will end up in
remember those random npc characters
that you fought during fears questline
what about the npcs that you fought in
front of the great jar
well a recent discovery has revealed
that these are actually the uploaded
characters of other real players and
there must be millions of options that
the game is actually choosing from
matt gruen on twitter has revealed some
of the incredible workings behind this
system for example if you're online
while getting hugged by fear then your
character's build is allegedly being
uploaded to the elden ring servers and
apparently these saved builds are then
passively loaded while in the deep root
depths that means your character can
actually appear as fierce champion in
another player's game a similar thing
happens when you receive the great jars
arsenal where your character can then
appear as a knight of the great jar in a
different player's world but even if
your character is uploaded matt points
out that it doesn't mean your build will
always be used
we don't yet know the inner workings of
this system there must be some other
requirements to make sure these builds
aren't completely non-functional but
it's so damn cool that elden ring can
pull your build out of its enormous jar
of warriors so to speak
crazy discovery next you'll have noticed
that ruins are a pretty common sight on
your journey through the lands between
thing is these always seem to have
underground areas with treasures or
bosses or two bosses but while most
ruins have obvious entrances to their
underground others conceal them with
planks or even magic so if you find a
ruin without an underground area try
your best to look for an illusory floor
an easy way to spot them is by looking
for a rectangle that doesn't quite blend
in
as you can see here
you can also use the incantation law of
regression which reveals mimicry but an
even better version is the omen shackle
items which are kind of bugged and have
a huge hitbox that can trigger illusory
walls to open
for number 23 there have been some
quality of life updates added in recent
patches as well that are proving pretty
helpful in their own small ways a really
useful one is this small glowing icon
that now appears at the site of grace
menu it indicates that you have flask
upgrades on hand so now you know exactly
when you have enough sacred tears or
golden seeds to craft and upgrade with
for number 24 alongside the flask update
the item description for golden runes
now finally says how many runes you'll
gain from consuming them on their
description page it reads that the rune
is used to gain x amount of runes making
it a much easier way to consume based on
exactly what you need
as far as updates go though redan might
be the boss who's undergone the most
since the game's release the conqueror
of stars is still tough to beat but
there is another way you can approach
this fight that will make it a little
less difficult
so this video from limit breakers shows
that you can actually fully defeat radan
just by using npc summons limit breakers
found that there are 10 banners in the
boss arena and that each one has a
collection of summon signs beneath it
that never changes in total there are 41
summon signs but each one can only be
used once
limit breaker's helpful graphic really
breaks it all down you should go and
watch his video but basically blythe can
be summoned six times as can lionel try
goth and geron although geron only
appears in phase two which i found
interesting because it's basically like
he's only joining in on the fight when
he knows radan is probably going to die
okina and finger maiden therolina can be
summoned five times alexander can be
used three times and patches can be
summoned four times though he kind of
just pieces out immediately if you do
summon him which is hilarious but even
without patches that's 37 fighters which
is basically an army and while it does
take them a while to chip away at
radan's health you can also use buffs
like the commander's standard to help
them out in the end the summons can do
quite a number on the big guy which is
especially relevant if you're under
leveled just be ready for quite a long
battle
in fact while you're riding around
during this long battle why not listen
to some audiobooks this month i'd like
to recommend 1q84 by murakami which you
can listen to completely free just head
over to audible.com varietyvideo or text
variety video to 500 500 and claim your
30-day free audible trial to get full
access to thousands and thousands of all
you can listen audiobooks original
entertainment and podcasts as well
included in the plus catalog
but if you want you can use your free
trial on the murakami book i recommended
and murakami books are pretty legendary
i think everyone should read at least
one they're these stories that are often
grounded in reality but
they have a reality that really starts
to unwind and takes the reader on an
intense journey here's a small excerpt
from 1q84
be careful it looks windy out there
don't slip
i'll be careful aomami said
and also the driver said facing the
mirror
please remember
things are not what they seem
if this sounds good to you then go to
audible.com
or text vaatividia to 500 500 and get
your free trial started today thank you
to audible for sponsoring this video and
thank you for watching